Nos piden graficar la función "f" de "x" igual a "5x" menos 4.
Muy bien lo que vamos a hacer es tomar una muestra
de algunos puntos del dominio,
vamos a ver cuánto vale la función en esos puntos,
los vamos a poner en un plano coordenado
y después vamos a conectar esos puntos,
para ver cómo es la gráfica de la función.
Hay otras formas en las cuales se puede graficar,
pero esta es la más sencilla,
así que empecemos con eso.
Observemos que "f" está definida en todos los reales,
cualquier real, lo podemos multiplicar
por 5 y luego restarle 4.
Entonces déjame pintar por aquí el eje "x", vamos a pensar que este de acá es el eje "x",
vale, y por acá voy a poner el eje "y"...
el eje "y"...
y vamos a ponerle que "y"
va a ser igual a "f" de "x"
es decir, ahorita vamos
a trazar la gráfica de la función "f" de "x"
y por lo tanto la coordenada en "y" la obtenemos
metiendo el valor de x "en" la función, vale,
bueno, vamos a tomar algunos puntos del dominio,
para eso déjame hacer una tabla,
aquí voy a tomar una tabla,
en donde voy a poner aquí los valores de "x"
y acá los "y",
que es "f" de "x"...
y bueno esta muestra de valores...
no, no va a ser una  muestra de valores muy grandes
o muy complicados
queremos que las cosas sean sencillas.
Aquí podría poner 20 millones,
pero sería muy latoso después
calcular "f" de 20 millones.
Entonces déjame poner aquí algunos números facilitos,
que van a ir de -2 a 2,
y van a brincar de 1 en 1 vale,
bueno, voy a comenzar con el -2,
aquí le voy a poner -2
muy bien,
¿si x es igual a -2 cuánto es "y"?
Bueno pues sería igual a "f" de "x"
y "f" de "x" sería 5 por "x" menos 4
pero "x" es -2,
entonces nos quedaría
5... 5 por -2
y luego tenemos que restar 4, vale,
5 por -2 es -10 menos 4 es -14...
-14... va,
entonces uno de los puntos
en esta gráfica va a ser el -2, -14
déjame ponerle por aquí este... la escala
para que sepamos dónde están los puntos
entonces déjame tomar el color amarillo otra vez...
y voy a poner por aquí...
mmm...
pues a ver aquí va a estar el -2,
acá va a estar el -1,
y el 0,
el 1,
y el 2,
y para el eje "y", pues voy a poner mira...
tenemos un -14, entonces,
déjame poner por aquí el -5,
por aquí el -10,
por acá el -15,
-5, -10,
-15
y en los valores positivos voy a poner por aquí el 5
por acá 10,
muy bien ahora sí?
¿Dónde quedaría este punto?
el -2, -14
pues tenemos que tomar el punto que está en -2,
aquí...
y que está en menos 14 acá,
déjame bajar con una línea punteada...
el -14 queda más o menos como por acá,
entonces el punto que nos interesa es éste, vale,
este es uno de los puntos de la gráfica
de la función el -2, -14,
vamos a seguir con otros puntos.
por ejemplo,
si aquí le pongo "x" igual a -1,
tenemos que hacer 5 por -1,
menos 4,
5 por -1 es -5 menos 4 es igual a -9,
vale,
entonces ahora tenemos el punto -1,  -9
por aquí que del -9,
entonces más o menos es este punto de acá, vale.
Entonces este de acá es el -1, -9
muy bien,
ese es otro punto en la gráfica de "f"...
déjame tomar el color morado...
para poner aquí el cero...
entonces "f" de "x" sería, 5 por 0...
5 por 0 menos 4,
que sería igual a 5 por 0 es 0,
y nos queda -4,
muy bien,
entonces el punto ahora es el 0, -4
0, -4
este punto está sobre el eje "y".
Vale, entonces ahí ya tenemos 3 puntos
y este de acá le voy a poner que es el 0, -4
muy bien vamos al color azul...
para ver cuánto es "f" de 1,
si "x" es 1, "y" es "f" de 1
que es 5 por 1 menos 4,
5 por 1 es 5 menos 4 es igual a 1,
entonces tendríamos el punto 1, 1
Por aquí queda más o menos el 1,
entonces tendríamos
este punto de por acá,
vale, este de acá es el 1, 1
y finalmente voy a ponerle 2,
lo voy a poner con color verde...
entonces el 2 nos da 5 por 2 menos 4,
5 por 2 es 10 menos 4 es 6
y por lo tanto, el punto... el último punto que nos interesa
está más o menos, por acá,
por acá está el 6
y entonces este punto es el 2, 6
muy bien, entonces recuerda,
hasta ahorita solo tenemos una muestra
de los valores de la función "f"
en algunos puntos de su dominio
-2, -1, 0, 1, 2.
Si queremos obtener la gráfica,
lo que tenemos que hacer es unir estos puntos,
entonces déjame unirlos con color blanco...
y bueno si tuviera un buen pulso,
podemos ver que la idea general,
es que esta gráfica es una línea
¿va? entonces uniendo estos puntos...
ahí voy... más o menos...
uniendo estos puntos obtenemos una línea
bueno ahí, me quedó un poco chueco
por mi pulso, pero bueno...
si tuviera reglas nos quedaría una línea...
y por lo tanto la gráfica de la función,
ahora sí, la gráfica de la función es esta línea blanca,
y lo importante es que esta gráfica
ya tiene los puntos correspondientes
a todos los puntos del dominio,
por ejemplo, aquí nos comparamos el 1.5,
entonces el punto correspondiente sería éste.
si nos tomáramos el -0.5
entonces,
el punto correspondiente sería este, vale,
entonces lo importante es que ya ,terminamos.
Esto de aquí, es la gráfica de la función
"f" de "x" igual a "5x" menos 4.